[Applause]
[Applause]
a rakish tilt to a hat the drape of
fabric just so nuance and sophistication
are just two qualities of the most
effective costume design these artists
create a pastiche of textiles with
authenticity
yet never distract from the story
costume designers construct the looks
that ground a character to a particular
time and place in the subtlest subtlest
of ways
so true so true so true so true
here are the nominees for achievement
and costume design The Ballad of Buster
Scruggs costume design by Nell his offer
is black panther costume design Babu
kana
the favorite costume design by Sandeep
our Mary Poppins returns costume design
by santolli
Mary Queen of Scots costume designer by
Alexandra Berg and the Oscar goes to
okay okay
[Applause]
Black Panther
[Applause]
she was previously
for Malcolm X and
Scot
[Applause]
I got it Wow this has been a long time
coming Spike Lee thank you for my start
I hope this makes you proud
[Applause]
Marvel may have created the first black
superhero but through costume design we
turned him into an African King it's
been my life's honor to create costumes
thank you to the Academy thank you for
honoring African royalty and the
empowered way women can look and lead
on-screen thank you to my cruise around
the world who helped bring what Conda to
life our genius director Ryan Coogler
you are a guiding force thank you for
your trust in understanding my role in
telling the African American story
adding vibranium to costumes is very
expensive so thank you Victoria
Alonzo Kevin Feige Luis Esposito J
Jeffrey turnoff Bob Iger and make more
[Applause]
with passion to tell stories that allow
us to know ourselves better
this is for my 97 year old mother
watching in Massachusetts thank you for
teaching me about people and their
stories you are the original superhero
thank you
[Applause]